Hm.
>> What's up?
>> So it looks like I
misspelled my email here as
americanguyw1521@mail.com instead
of @gmail.com.
But it's still letting me log in.
>> Actually yeah, it's not really
checking whether the email address
actually exists or
whether you own the email.
It just kind of checks whether it's
formatted like an email address.
>> Hm, interesting.
>> Wait, so hypothetically,
someone else could sign in with
someone else's personal email address.
>> Yeah, I guess, if they wanted to.
>> Intriguing.
>> Shoot.
I think I forgot my password.
Does that mean I'm locked
out of my account?
>> No, here, let me log in,
I can reset it.
>> No, that's okay.
I'll just make another one
under my correct email address.
What?
It looks like it's already taken.
I bet it was J.P.
[NOISE].